my friend Andy has been working on a new
comedy bit for the last couple of weeks
and just before the show he told me he
wants to try it out tonight
are you ready with this thing Andy yes I
am all right okay Andy go ahead with
your comedy piece remember this remember
this remember this remember this okay up
to Andy could you stop a second
what's wrong that's that's not really a
comedy piece all you're doing is saying
remember this and then showing pictures
of stuff well yeah that's the beginning
of it you stopped it before it could
change it changes now oh I'm sorry I
interrupted it okay fine go ahead okay
remember him Eddie Andy stop it any all
you did was change member this to
remember him and remember her that's all
you did
uh-huh come on Conan it's a trip down
memory lane everybody loves it right
that's stupid so stupid
Andy anyone can do that Alan give me a
screen I'll do it okay here we go
remember this
remember this remember this Oh none of
this okay
take those down now and take it down
yeah not so easy is it no that's not
fair Andy I'm trying to do a comedy show
and now the crowds obsessed Conan I
think I can help remember this
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]